ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show here it is Thanksgiving
weekend uh we are pre-recording the show
quite a few days before the actual
holiday we have many many things to do
we've got a we've got a a real special
guest coming
up uh that'll come out on Monday yeah
next week next week and then we're
taking a we're taking a little holiday
so you've got you're going to have two
episodes to
binge and then we'll see you in December
probably or late November however that
works um and I'm very excited about this
guest no a tishby coming back on stop
why am I why would I stop why would I
ever stop I'll never
stop trying to get no what to come back
on this show
and tank
it further in
views that episode tanks so badly that I
should have
Hezbollah
on every day for a week because that
thing ate
it what are you gonna do Timothy shalam
uh uh what's going on over here in uh
Japan or I think he's promoting the
Wonka film I just don't love this let's
just take a look at this here
[Music]
I don't I mean that is that are they in
the film
no so they're just
making it it feels
like those children have been they've
they've had to do that and food has been
withheld from them
until they did it just like that like I
feel like I don't even he seems like
he's like oh whoa what's what's going on
Wow W one more time
here it's just
uncomfortable are they children or they
like do they have a disease where
they're like
30 like the Dobby girl like uh uh
uh I am I will never I am a huge fan
right now of
uh is it zza and woong get up zhaa and
woong zza is a 36y old yeah this one go
to the third one down there this is a
good one uh she is from a province in
China and she's big on Chinese Tik Tock
and her friend woong is kind kind of a
hunchback and zzza has her own issues
but um and this
transgender presenter in China China
seems kind of fun like I know that we're
all supposed to be afraid of
China but if this is what's going on in
China Count Me In they've got this
transgender presenter who's very
polished and put together uh who looks
very good she's like going the full you
know she's really she's going the full
you
know whatever it is you know doing it uh
I don't want to say right doing it well
it's
nice you know I'm GNA get in trouble for
saying this and I and people are going
to get angry with me and I don't know
I'm just
saying sometimes it's nice to see a
transgender person really
try do you understand what I
mean because I like effort in every part
of life do you understand it's not I'm
only I'm not simply requiring it of
someone who's transitioning or changing
genders I want it all over the
place but I do like it when I see
someone who is
transgender really commit to it and
really try to the best of their own
Financial ability Mark Norman used to
have a great joke about that where he
was like people say this one's Brave
she's just rich or whatever you know but
I like to see somebody try which this
host in China is doing and this is kind
of like I guess a Chinese American Idol
in a
way I don't know I don't know if that's
what it it is but let's give everyone a
taste of this if you don't know who
these people
are this will
be cultural prediction
here this will be more common we are
going to find people that are
deformed because this is kind of the
Final
Phase of society where it's really the
barbarism is coming I every week I try
not to do this by the way like every
week I go I drive here and I go you know
I know why I'm not as big as like other
people it's just because it's like how
much can you take of this right like
even me like even me sometimes right I'm
like how much can I take like I want to
do other things like I had a nice
friend's giving talk about that I could
talk about entertaining I like I like
throwing uh you know parties and seeing
people get together who cares right but
I get it like like I was like today on
the way here I was like I'm not going to
do the whole it's fall the Empire is
falling in I I'm not gonna do it but I
really I sometimes I don't want to do it
but it's just it's now what is there
it's so if it's you know there's it's
it's hard to infer anything else from
the news is my point it's difficult I
try to to infer we're gonna go later Fox
News literally has an article that's
like here's how you can have a
Thanksgiving without killing people that
you
know because they're so used to the
people that watch Fox News as being like
I guess like monsters that they
literally every line is like well you
know you don't you know don't keep a
loaded gun at the table like it's such a
crazy article but what I mean here about
Xiao Xiao and wulong and I think why
they're an important you know I know
that I mean even as I say this it seems
insane but what's important about xiaa
and wulang is
that we're I believe what's coming is a
real fascination with deformed people
kind of freaks it's going back to the 19
20s as it was in the beginning as it
shall be in the end I believe we are
going back to the kind of tent era
depression tent era Carnival Sideshow
circus this is what I believe this is
kind of the final form of a lot of the
trends that we've seen on the
internet these people are probably being
abused they're being used but they're
getting their Fame and you know people
are going to say this is a good thing
you know people
people debate this they go these are
these people are being abused and then
other people go no they're not they love
it and no one knows what's going on
because no one lives in this crazy
province of China but I think her
family's probably like we're making a
little bit of money here people like
this she's an odity she's an odity MH
and this was the thinking behind the
freak Show right this person is an
oddity but why not pay
money to see
them because so this is what a lot of
tick tock has become we are putting
humans on display and human
Oddities and we
are marveling at them we're
gawking and the latest manifestation of
this is Xiao xia and wulang who by the
way I feel an affection for both of them
and I enjoy what they're doing Xiao xia
is a a kicks and hits because she's
often
angry at others which I often feel very
enraged and I
feel kind of envious of her of her
ability to kind of just kind of wo long
her friend who only I've read about them
for several hours and wo I had a party
it's funny you know I had this friends
giving and I I you talk what I like
about it is you don't talk to anyone for
that long you do your little thing with
everybody you go over to Caitlyn Jenner
how are you she's talking about
patriotism love it go over to Barry
Weiss What's your deal the Jews good
moving on we go over to tan Mojo like
her what's going on with the
[__] you just quick quick in and out
Bobby Lee Lovely to meet your girl this
one that one that one you know Santino a
bunch of people came but for a lot of
the party I was reading about xiaa and
wulong because I was I'm
transfixed and they said this all
started because Xiao Xiao they they they
were doing some type of benefit for Xiao
xia they brought her out she sang a song
her people liked it supposedly woong
only spoke one word before she
started doing so social
media these are the Chinese demilios you
know how we have Charlie demilio and
Dixie
demilio this is what they have and I
take these two over the demilios any day
of the week without further Ado if you
don't know them you will they're going
to be household
names uh is this show part of the
problem or part of the solution I don't
know
I don't know if there's a real
[Music]
difference now if that's what Wonka was
I'd watch him
shiao and woong find them support them
on all their
channels woong doesn't sing often she's
chill but she does sing sometimes you
know this is what's happening this is
where where life is going Fox News just
ran an article Fox News likes to run
articles occasionally where they're
basically like
listen occasionally you're gonna go into
the world
and um you know a friend of mine is
lives down in Florida just h the qanon
store this is true she open a qanon
boutique in like a uh in a old motel in
Florida they just let you transact
business which I like so they have these
old motels and we'll talk about the
commercial real estate crash in a little
bit too but she opened this kind of it's
just a qinon store it just looks like a
hoarder house she's got like
games from the
90s that kids can buy like fun Trump
sweatshirts mhm it's just a q Anon
Boutique in Florida for people that are
older that are in the
area and want to go to the qanon store
you know
and so what Fox News has to do every now
and then is run an article where they're
basically like
hey you're gonna have relatives that
don't shop at your K on store and you're
going to have to eat turkey with them
how do you do it how do you do it if
someone it's very funny because the
whole premise of the whole thing is like
someone's coming to your
house they don't agree with
you how can you do it how to handle
combative relatives during the holidays
welcome to attend with
conditions and this is on the fox News
website cuz Fox news by the way for
years has been
promoting all manner of crazy things
like a lot of news organizations
do MSNBC any of them their job if you
watch The Prime Time lineup is not to
inform you the job is to wind you
up and send you out into the world uh
like a whirling dervish where you are
just anywhere you can go spread the
gospel but now they're right every now
and then they'll throw out an article
where they're like hey it's
Thanksgiving so C there might be people
that show up at your house that do not
they're not they don't get it like you
get it they're not in the program like
you're in the program they don't know
about the underground tunnels you do
so you're GNA have to just make a choice
you're gonna have to ban
them from
speaking or you're gonna have to set
boundaries because it's your house and
you get to decide what's real and what's
not in your house this is your reality
they're stepping into your reality so
whatever you've decided is the truth
they got to subscribe to
that quote if you're worried about the
possibility of fights or quarrels or
over any number of topics during the
holiday season mental health experts
which by the way what a great term and
God Only
Knows mental health experts shared
strategies and insights for how to
defuse arguments and how to speak to
relatives about your
concerns don't buy into the belief that
you have a perfect family or that the
holiday will be perfect said Jonathan
Alpert a psychotherapist and executive
performance coach right right always
right right go back
up executive performance
coach it's always something else when
these experts weigh in it's never like
just some type of do doctor it's like
doctor and con artist like
psychotherapist
and con artist and uh you know
Primerica
executive uh it's a
psychotherapist and sells Mary K
Cosmetics um this person has practices
in Manhattan Washington DC and author of
the book be Fearless change your life in
28 days which you know I'm sure has a
lot of valuable information on being
fearless and changing your life in 28
days if you'd want
to by adjusting your expectations you're
less likely to be disappointed and
stressed should something not go
according to plan and you'll be able to
take the pressure off yourself if you
know in advance there's bad blood
between relatives what can you do talk
to people ahead of time hold a
conversation with them separately about
your expectations with their behavior
said Amy Moren a psychotherapist and
author of 13 things mentally strong
people don't do all so Fox just tells
these people we'll plug your books just
we in yeah way into this article about
how people can behave we got to give
advice to our regular viewers about how
they can behave like people for two
hours out of the year way in here
and we'll plug your book about uh 13
things mentally strong people don't
do hint number 13 look at the
poor they don't do it because they're
mentally
strong make it clear that they're
welcome to attend but that arguing or
rude Behavior won't be tolerated after
all you have others to think about
including your loved ones and
possibility your and possibly your
children and many other people you care
about
deeply refuse to take sides reconsider
serving alcohol can you ever just pick
one relative over another yes you can
certainly just pick one relative over
the
other sometimes family riffs stem from
serious issues like childhood abuse
crime or substance abuse you don't have
to invite people to your home just
because they are related to you right so
if someone in your family is uh raped
everyone in a family Fox News is telling
you you don't have to invite them but
what if they agree with me well that's
tough that's hard if the rapist is on
your side politically it becomes
different you know you're a neutral
party who wants to invite everyone and
you aren't interested in listening to
complaints about the other person you
might just decide to pick one relative
because you want them to feel
emotionally safe or because you want
them to attend the Gathering and they
wouldn't if the other person was there
do you warn both people to be on their
best behavior ahead of
time who is this
for who is this who is this for what
person is sitting at home going God I
just I don't know I don't know I don't
know how to do it look at this what if
the relative isn't at odds with a
particular guest but just has a
combative personality Fox is B they're
basically like what if this
person is gonna come there and say
something you're uncomfortable with what
do you do what could you do how do you
turn your Thanksgiving table into a
fascist
dictatorship of which you are the
dictator that's really what it comes
down to that's the whole article the
whole article like how do you because
they they bury it in the mental health
crap which they don't care about at all
and they're basically like yeah how can
you avoid
disagreement how can you avoid
disagreement now several people have the
benefit of armies or intelligence
services that will disappear people that
disagree with them now you may not have
the financial wherewithal to do that or
you may live uh in in a in a a type of
place where uh murdering is outright
illegal so what you have to do is find
different ways to shut down anyone that
would disagree with you about
anything because we here at Fox we know
what you want to do we know what you
want to do you've hosted the event and
you've hosted the event because you want
to basically get everyone around the
table and and yell and scream about the
Guatemalans now that's fine but someone
might ruin this by going hey they're
they're people kind of right like the
softest
defense they might provide like the
thinnest defense of for example like
like somebody at the kitchen table might
be like you know it feels like 12,000
people's a lot of people to kill in Gaza
then people like you're out of line
you're turning this h holiday upside
down you sick
[__] Fox News how do you turn your
Thanksgiving into a fascist dictatorship
where everyone is afraid to have a
different opinion look at this I love
this how do you keep hot topics out of
the conversation this is very fox goes
this is very difficult to do as we
cannot control other people by the way
this is not there's no idea here like
the so we're supposed to believe that
the person who's reading this on
foxnews.com
is a just an innocent
Wallflower who's terrified this is the
Fox News Watcher they're terrified about
people coming to their house and
starting
up it's very difficult to do as we
cannot control other
people however if and when hot topics
come up you could set a boundary by
saying something like let's not get into
XYZ it could be controversial and we're
all having a good time why don't we talk
about ABC
instead can you say to a relative I
can't have this in my home
again I can't have this in my home again
like last
year and by it I mean you're mixed race
child I think it would be better if you
visited another day as challenging as it
be to tell a relative not to come to a
holiday it might be what it it's just
the premise of this is hilarious the
idea that like a a Fox News Watcher is
like well we just like to have a
Thanksgiving that's uncomplicated but
then people come in with all their
ideas all their ideas and me and my
husband just sit there and we're just
sitting there and serving everybody
turkey and reading minec conf but then
these kids come in with their ideas
is think about what is in the best
interest of the group how orwellian is
all this that's it yeah so
orwellian a conversation like this can
lead to hard feelings but having a
relative come over who does not get
along with other relatives can also lead
to hard feelings what is it like what
world are we living in where there's
articles being written about like hey
man someone might come to your house and
you might have a disagreement here's a
10-point plan to make sure that doesn't
happen I mean how crazy is
that and then everybody's like
everybody's in a bubble everyone's in a
why is everyone in such a bubble
everyone's in a feedback loop nobody's
uh yeah because you have articles
telling people the mildest disagree like
make sure draw the lines draw the battle
lines before they get there let them
know it's like guys let [__] fly let it
[__] happen it's Thanksgiving that's
what it's supposed to be people are
supposed to disagree and fight it's
supposed to be
uncomfortable people are supposed to sit
on a couch you know in that trip to fan
Hayes you know in a coma from the turkey
and they're supposed to just you know
start fighting you know about nonsense
that's the whole point of the holiday
they're supposed to argue everybody is
so ill informed at a holiday party it's
great and then they're all tired and
drunk and they don't really know what
they're talking about and that's when
you get real raw fun collisions of bad
ideas that both parties have and that's
what we should do why are we trying to
avoid that it's the literal point of the
holiday it's the point of the you don't
care about seeing your cousin for the
most part it's fun to watch stuff pop
off when my father and his wife brought
their
dogs to my to my grandmother's house and
my uncle flipped out and screamed about
it and he was in the right by the way
you just stop bringing your dogs places
if they're not invited it's just what it
is I love my father and his wife but I'm
just saying in this uh you know
particular instance I thought my uncle
had a point there you know that's a that
that I think that's good m why avoid
that you know I grew up in an Irish
family where people fought a lot
sometimes physically there was a lot of
uh you know a lot of loud people a lot
of opinions a lot of hostility being
expressed I think that's incredibly
healthy I I I don't think avoiding all
of that is uh good I think it's part of
the fun part of the fun of a
Thanksgiving is to get it
going like like if you're a young P tell
them tell them you're in Hamas at
Thanksgiving go I am in
Hamas can be show up in a a a
hijab give your grandmother a
stroke and then just go I'm
kidding tell them you converted to Islam
in the car on the way over have fun you
only live what these the memory you're
making
memories I mean what's the
point everything that has any value is a
controversial topic for the most
part so I mean I guess you could just
talk about yourselves like a bunch of
narcissists but immediately get
immediately get into the Middle East
it's why they're fighting over there so
we can talk about it at our Thanksgiving
table
that's why it's happening what do you
think Hamas did it with a bunch of power
you think they did it for nothing they
did it so that you could talk about it
while you stuff marshmallows in your
face that's the benefit of Living in
America up until the point everybody
nukes us which is coming but the benefit
of Living in America is being able to
discuss things that have real
consequences for other people and you
get to discuss them quite flippantly and
casually you get to discuss life and
death decisions pretty casually with no
information you're we're all it's all
like kind of game of throny with the
goblets of wine and eating their turkey
well you get better you gotta kill them
you gotta kill them good well they have
to do because they're in a h they're
under the hospital that's why you don't
know cuz they're in schools those people
so the kids are at the school but you
got to kill the people under the school
that's where it is that's what you have
to do this is the benefit of being in
the benefit of being an American is that
you get to
engage quite casually in uh discussions
and topics that uh are they have real
consequences for people all over the
world and you get to just sound off on
them from the minute you can talk you're
allowed to to do this and there's no
better time to do it than the holidays
there's no better time there's a captive
audience everybody's eating and drinking
you don't see these people a lot it's
good to see what they're into and
about why not why avoid it what are you
gonna [__] talk
about it's so
boring if you're if you're gonna like I
like a little bit of
and you know we were
pretty we would fight about personal
things my family more more so than
political but I don't think there's
anything
wrong with having a knockdown drag out
what by two ill-informed
people on either side of an issue that
don't really have any facts and are
arguing to mask the E emotional problems
that they are having that don't don't
have anything to do with this issue that
they don't really care that much about I
don't think there's anything wrong with
masing uh the emotional pit of despair
you were in because you're in a Loveless
marriage uh by screaming about uh Gaza I
don't think there's anything wrong with
it I I think it's as Amer it's as
American as apple pie if apple pie is
American going to Thanksgiving with your
Loveless wife uh your Loveless marriage
your wife who hates you and you hate her
and you just you know you're just doing
it you're doing it because you've been
doing it for a while but you know it's
coming to an end you know dating after
40 ain't great and you know there's
going to be a lot of lonely nights and
you're gonna have to get back on the
horse and you know your wife uh you know
is basically she's going to rebound a
lot quicker than you and that bothers
you too and you know you know this you
know it and as you drive your moderately
expensive
SUV uh to uh your brother's house who
always had more money than you he was
always a little better looking than you
his family's a little better than yours
he cheats on his wife she doesn't really
mind or maybe she doesn't even know
she's dumb she's from the south you
should have married a southern woman but
you didn't you married a a New Yorker
and she was smart she went to Vasser she
was smarter than you she pretended she
didn't want or care about money but you
know down deep she did and you know down
deep she look at your brother's house
and his car and things like that all the
things that you pretended not to care
about well it turns out she was a
[__] liar cuz she makes a lot of
passive aggressive comments about your
income level and it bothers you and you
don't find her attractive and you
haven't had sex in 8 months and 8 months
ago was you could barely get hard for
her you're just not into it anymore but
you can't go into that at Thanksgiving
so you have to scream and yell about
Gaza or trans kids or uh I don't know
what's a
guns because you you're you're in a pit
of emotional pain pain and
despair and it can only and it can only
be solved one way and that way is by
coming in with talking
points and getting uh on a high horse
and feeling morally
Superior and there's nothing wrong with
that that's the point of the holiday is
to mask your
pain I think it's a beautiful thing and
you can when you are at your
Thanksgiving this has come out after
Thanksgiving
but you can tell somebody's getting
really uh into something go this isn't
really about this isn't about you know
immigration is it this is about
something else you have other
issues but listen there's nothing wrong
with a passionate exchange of ideas and
information it's what America is about
it's what America's about at nauseum I
keep repeating this how how how how
people text me all the time they go hey
what what beds you have in your house in
the guest rooms that we all love and I
go the midnight Delux from Helix they go
damn it it's the nicest bed I've ever
slept on in my life and and I'm telling
that they're like what is it and I go
Helix go really I go
yeah I'm telling you right now Helix is
offering 25% off all mattress orders and
free sleep bundle for our listeners in
honor of Black Friday the bundle
includes two free pillows as well as a
set of sheets and even a mattress
protector go to helixsleep.com
timd this is actually really smart
aren't a good thing to do they are the
best beds I have everybody loves them
shopping for a mattress is insane the
salespeople are all like emotionally
disturbed by the way if you ever go to
like a mattress sales but it's like you
had a Temperpedic in there and the
people there are like
sick um timd is the code you go to
helixsleep.com you can take a quiz and
the midnight Deluxe is where it's at but
you can still take a quiz and they'll
basically tell you what's the perfect
mattress for you because maybe the
mattresses my friends love and family
are not ones that your friends and
family will love but I'm telling you
right now you take a quiz they find out
everything about you uh your sleeping
style they're offering 25% off all
mattresses you get two free pillows set
of sheets mattress protector all for
free you've got to be crazy enough to do
I may do it
actually helixsleep.com timd use the
code Helix partner2 helixsleep.com
timd and use the code Helix partner 25
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now there's so much to be
thankful for family friends food and NFL
football all week long draftking
Sportsbook is keeping your Thanksgiving
week full of action new customers can
bet just five bucks on the NFL action to
score 150 instantly in bonus bets it's
not a bad deal no matter your appetite
there's something for you money lines
parlays props live bats so much more you
name it they've got it download the
draftking Sportsbook app now use code
Tim Dylan new customers can bet five on
the NFL thank Thanksgiving action to get
150 instantly in bonus bets hey guys
that's called a
deal okay a good one only on draftking
sports book an official sports betting
partner of the NFL with code Tim
Dylan the crown is
yours and this I gotta read this whole
thing right it Alexs
yeah gambling problem call- 1800 Gambler
in New York call 8778 Hope New York or
text Hope New York 467 369 in West West
Virginia visit ww. 1800 gambler. net
please play responsibly and Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call 188 78977 77 or visit ccpg dorg on
behalf of booill Casino and Resort
Kansas must be 21 older in most eligible
states by the age varies by jurisdiction
see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details and state specific responsible
gambling resources eligibility and
deposit restrictions apply bonus bats
expire 168 hours after issuance terms at
sportsbook.com
football terms the commercial real
estate crisis is deepening um and it's
something that
suggests a reckoning is
coming after Co people did not return to
work they
didn't vacancy rates are
High um what's the big one that just
went out of business we were work M we
work was like Airbnb for
companies they would just have these uh
office spaces thousands tens of
thousands of square feet for people that
needed to work now everybody's working
from home people don't go into offices
as
much people do not you know have those
um communities that they used to have I
mean offices are huge there are
workplace comedies in America there was
a hit show called the office right it
you're amputating a major part of
American culture if you just send
everybody into their
house the office is where people meet
their friends it's where people meet
people they're going to marry it's where
you know they have a lot of the
formative
experiences as a younger intern or
somebody you looking at these old people
in your office and you're going [__] I
don't want to end up like that guy or
God you know what I wouldn't give to end
up like that guy and I worked in tons of
them and I and I know exactly that that
is what's happening and I I worked with
them as a young guy having those things
when
you it's very interesting to look at the
evolution of a physical Society into a
digital one
which is what's happening
where the new office is a zoom meeting
it's a Microsoft uh Meetup or whatever
it's called Google Hangout whatever
these things are called and that's the
new office and and and people are not
going into a physical structure and they
are staying home and they are you know
more isolated than they've been and they
don't they don't know their co-workers
as well as they would have if they sat
next to them or went to lunch with them
when you are face Toof face with
somebody the relationship you build is
different than the one that you build
digitally this is just Mark Zuckerberg
might he might not want to hear that the
people that are making billions of
dollars shutting everybody into their
homes and you know hooking them up to a
computer like an IV don't want to hear
that it is significant to be in
someone's physical presence sitting
there talking to them hearing them
instead diminishing uh everything to
online is uh I think going to
be quite a negative for people I don't
think it's good for people to
work number one I don't think it's good
for people's
marriages and this we saw this during
the pandemic I I think people have to
get out get out of their house you know
I have lots of friends at work from home
and some of them it works out but but
some of
them it's not working out it's it's it's
it's putting a strain on the
marriage to be in the same
house every minute of every
day and they're they don't have this
social you know community that they
had but commercial real estate is going
to is probably going to collapse uh
people cannot get loans the way the
commercial mortgages work is
that people are constantly refinancing
them they're constantly modifying them
and if they can't get new loans those
things are hard to do and they head into
foreclosure um this is from the post a
commercial real estate market is headed
for a severe collapse due to in large
part Skyhigh interest rates and
declining property values nobody wants
these properties anymore because they
know it's not boom times they know
they're not going to get the rents that
they would want they know that a lot of
these properties are going to sit vacant
when asked when they believe the price
of office properties will hit
bottom 44% said they expected that to
happen in the second half of next year
while 222% said it will be in the final
six months of
2024 just
6% of the 919 respondent said that
prices would bottom out this year so
people think this is a
long slide 30% of people are saying it
won't bounce back till 2025 or
beyond the FED has raised rates
aggressively over and over again and
there is just less which is why you know
it's like you know my friend who's got a
little QQ on Boutique in
Florida you know it's in an old Motel
and it's kind of clever what they're
doing there because they have this old
Motel where you
can put set up a
boutique of the magit and the kunon
memorabilia
regalia why not why not you know I'm
telling you right now some 270 billion
in commercial real estate loans held by
banks are set to mature in
2023 according
to trap over the next four years
commercial real estate properties must
pay off debt maturities that will Peak
at
billion according to analyst and Morgan
Stanley vacancy rates are at 30-year
highs in many American
cities q1 of 2023 New York City vacancy
rate
22.2% that is the most dynamic IC city
in the world the largest Central
business district in the world New
York wow San Francisco I mean forget
it the vacancy rate in San Francisco
is I don't know exactly what it is but I
imagine
it's very high oh yeah and this is
um this is a this is a bigger story I
think that people realize because what
it
signifies um is the collapse
of a way of life for many people for a
very long time it doesn't mean that it's
going to be
33.9% vacancy rate San
Francisco
34% vacant space Office Buildings just
sitting there nobody
working they go yeah yeah yeah I'm good
I'll do it from home yeah Don Donna came
in to work yesterday she got
slashed what D you know Donna well Donna
came into the office she got slashed
across her face yeah so we're listen
just if you're gonna come in be careful
yeah I think I'll just work from home
that's fine too but if you're GNA just
come in like we we're telling everyone
to use the Market Street entrance
because um you know Donna used the kind
of main entrance and somebody just came
up to her and and and and slashed her
thank God it was you know it wasn't a
knife it was a pen but she has ink
poisoning and they just kind of jabbed
at her with a pen a few times but you
know Donna she's not a small woman and
she fought back so I mean they're saying
it's not nearly as bad as it should have
been well anyway get me that report when
you can't like it's not a good time in
San Francisco to get people uh into the
office but I don't know where it is like
I don't know where it uh where people
are uh you know obviously there's
certain jobs you have to be in an office
but there's a lot of
jobs people are doing them on the Fly
they're not they're going they're like
[__] it dude I'll work from Starbucks I
don't give a [__] I don't
care it's GNA be a thing of the past to
go you sit there you have an office
people used to take pride in their
office they used to sit all
day and they'd [__] their back up and
they'd order big
lunches and they'd do nothing really I
mean they would work for an hour or two
and then but this was people's life this
is a a big part of the Americana going
to the office the crazy
secretary the boss who's riding you your
buddy
Steve the fantasy football group crazy
Secret Terry
Dorene you know this is what Americana
we're
losing
Americana the hot receptionist you think
you got a shot with but you
don't all of these things are being
traded
in for these
sterile
horrible Zoom
culture where a bunch of disheveled
people from their disgusting
homes log on to a
hellscape it's it's really depressing to
me I was a you know I'm a big proponent
of work and I think offices are
great you know a lot of people don't
like that my uh socialist comrades hate
this cuz they Envision that work has no
meaning and life would be better if no
one had to work just like during the
pandemic when no one had a job remember
how peaceful that was remember how
peaceful and ideal that was when nobody
worked but I love offices I love them I
like being in them I like being in them
now and I know it's a terribly unpopular
thing to say people hate them they're
miserable I've been miserable in them
too you got to plot your way out or your
way up or something but they're not
nearly as bad as it as it could be when
you look at the way you know there's a
hell of a lot of people in developed
countries even countries like Russia as
a developed country a lot of those
people would love to go do data entry in
a Long Island office and drink uh a cup
of coffee with uh French vanilla creamer
in it and sit their fat ass in a chair
and just
click I mean
listen is it particularly uh inspiring
no but when you look at the realities of
lots of people's lives it gives you a
purpose we had this guy George used to
deliver mail he he was like deformed but
or he had cancer like melanomas on him
but he came every day he was so happy to
deliver the mail to the office he wasn't
some schmuck delivering mail on the
street those people are pedophiles he
was delivering it to the office and
sometimes the big guy would come out and
go hey George and they remembered his
name and like where do people like that
go where do people like that natal fat
Natalia she was so
big but she waddled in and sat her and
she was good at what she
did where do these people go where do
people go who derive a sense of purpose
and belonging from their job which is
again something that a lot of people
don't understand because they live in a
fantasy world that everybody's gonna
have a Disney adventure on the
planet and get absolutely everything
they want and they have all of these
passions that they just they're like
this job's keeping me from my passion
man I got to go out there and show the
world how special I am but like a lot of
people actually derive a certain amount
of fulfillment and meaning from their
job in an office doing nothing it's not
that important what they're doing
they're just not sitting in their
kitchen it's forced social interaction
for a lot of these
people and it worries
me because I think if you get rid of
these spaces and you just send people
back you know in back to their kitchen
tables and companies hire less people
you just end up with a a lot of
disaffected
unemployed
people that are even more isolated than
they were
before and that bothers
me it's not a bad
world uh the corporate uh world in in in
the sense that it's miserable in the way
like I have friends in it and all they
do is complain how much they hate it but
if you measure their lives against
people's lives all over the place they
have Superior
lives they
have Superior lives to a lot of not
everybody but a lot of
people and I know it's the coolest thing
in the world to be like [__] the
corporate where it sucks everything
sucks a [__] elevator [__] lose
this guy's on my back he wants this
report or
that but you know listen compared to
what what's the
alternative what's the alternative I I
don't know sitting in your
home sitting in the office You've Made
In Your Den I don't know dude that just
seems I know people with a lot of
freedom and sometimes too much freedom
is a bad thing I would love even though
I do what I do here I would love
to I would love to work a couple of days
a week at a
Geico I would love that I would
absolutely love for a couple of days a
week to just work at UH either a car car
insurance or something to just kind of
have a to have that feeling of like
getting in there you get your cup of
coffee sit down you open folders you
open a couple of files you get on the
computer here comes the emails we're all
rolling each other we're all rolling
eyes looking at each other like can you
[__] believe can you believe this can
you believe this [__] you know you go
out you smoke a cigarette with
somebody you talk about the company talk
about the business there's nothing
better than that there's nothing better
than being in a deadend job with other
losers I'm telling you all I'm around
right now as successful wealthy people
it's terrible it's miserable and
horrible horrible they all just want to
take iasa it's all these people want to
do is they're all so goddamn Rich all
they want to do is take um IA and open
their third eye and fourth eye and fifth
eye they want to all keep um just taking
uh different forms of DMT until the
aliens get so sick of them in hyperspace
they keep going you again these aliens
are in the other dimension going will
you go to work get a
job all these people are just every
every need you know every like
uh every need has been removed from
their lives so they're just like
endlessly trying to explore their inner
child they're like fingering their inner
child all the time it's like it's so
annoy like you can barely have a real
conversation with any of them because
they they they're they're up their own
ass so
far that they're
like it's crazy so there's nothing
better than being in a deadend job with
broke
losers who have given up because then
you're GNA actually have the best
conversations you some of the
deepest realest conversations I've ever
had with
anybody have certainly not at my friends
giving
but the the deepest realist a I've had
with anybody have been outside of like a
call center or a mortgage office or
whatever smoking a cigarette in an empty
parking lot going what the [__] are we
gonna do how are how does
this you become like war
buddies in a shitty job where people
aren't going anywhere you actually have
it it becomes
fun now yes there's negatives to that
I'm not an
idiot but what I am saying is like you
close down all the offices you throw
away all the French vanilla creamer you
throw away all the
curig what do you think happens what do
you think happens to people when you
send them back to their domiciles and
tell them to work from home we would
have fundraisers and
stuff you know this is is uh now people
hate it people hate it it's
uh roundly criticized uh as being a
meaningless a meaningless way to spend
your life what a meaning what a
meaningless way to spend your life in a
corporate Corporate America it's
meaningless you're so meaning to provide
for your wife and
kids God it's meaningless didn't you
ever want to
paint and this idea that everybody is
just uh shoving all their
dreams uh down deep into them and then
going and there's some of that for sure
but also we're trying it's a s we're
running a society here someone's got to
work not everyone can [__] around all
the time not everyone's Gonna Be A
Millionaire because they invented a sock
company people are going to need to work
someone's got to be a cog in a machine
someone's got to be that guy someone's
got to be the guy that walks into the
office you go oh God it's him someone's
got to be that someone's got someone's
got to be that the mail guy George who's
happy to give you the
mail where do these people go
everybody's not going this whole like
ethos of like online Hustler culture
that we think that like everybody is
just one crap psychology book away from
being the CEO of their own Empire is got
to stop it's got to go a convention is
nice going to a corporate convention
with other
losers is nice trying to get laid in a
corporate convention in in Cleveland
Ohio is a good
life you're not going to be a Kardashian
it does not haveen
happening it's not going to happen you
you you is things that are good the most
fun you're going to have is at a bar in
Cleveland Ohio at at at the
convention for pargal I don't know what
people do but the the point is this is a
good thing I I'm telling you that the
demise of commercial real estate is I I
worry about
it nothing would make me happier than
for a day or two
to just be part of a of a corporate
culture again to go in and get a get an
email get an
email turn around to my buddy like hey
man he goes you you you were out
yesterday o Deb was on a tear Deb was on
a tear dude Deb was on a [__] te
maybe trouble at home or something but
that [__] is
sick sick
like those convers it never happens
you're not allow it's like when you work
in those jobs you you're you're allowed
to hate it's encouraged you're allowed
to hate you're allowed to be bitter
resentful and and then you
know how are you GNA do that at home
that'll ruin your marriage your wife
doesn't care about your job she doesn't
want to hear about how much I hate
everybody that's why you have an office
you have friends you have Buddies you
get a cocktail after work you're I mean
that's that's got to go somewhere that
that resentment that ball of anger you
have inside of you it's got to go
somewhere it's got to go to your buddies
to the left to the right what's wrong
with Deb she's a sick [__] Deb's a sick
[__] she's sick couple of weeks ago she
thought she was having a stroke that's
how [__] wound up she gets one day
she is gonna have a stroke because she's
sick man that has to go
somewhere you can't say that to your
wife at your
house remember
Deb Deb she's an
underwriter well she's sick no not not
no not physically she just some she's
something's wrong with her I hate her I
hate her will you talk to me about how
much I hate it'll never work it'll never
you'll be on a street your wife will
leave your wife will say something like
maybe she's going through something
something and you're like oh God oh God
well what's this I'm telling you people
go oh it's just a commercial real estate
crisis it is amputating a an essential
part of American society and
civilization that is not that'll only be
replaced by the way by uh uh further
entering the dark Hamas tunnel of the
internet which is not good we're at
we're at 55 already yeah God so much
else I wanted to talk
about but does any thing I'm saying make
sense it
does this is a great uh defense here of
dead end jobs they're but they are
important
yeah they are really important and I
know that you don't agree with anything
I say because you you you know you drink
the Kool-Aid what do you mean meaning
that people at your generation has been
everything I'm saying about the Embrace
of the dead end job the Embrace of the
sterile corporate culture uh is
antithetical to everything that you have
been told and everything that I have
been told too which is to follow your
dream and the rest of all that
horeshit right we're supposed to Aspire
yeah right but don't you but don't you
agree with me yeah I mean there's got to
be uh pawns too I mean we all heard that
phrase it's not even about pawns it's
the happiest you'll ever be in your life
to try telling you well anyone listen to
me the happiest you'll ever be in your
life is it a dead end j you go you know
Deb I hope Deb gets shot in the
head I would love to see her shot in the
head everyone's laughing nothing's
better than a a a laugh at work a a
laugh at work your buddies go Chucks
hilarious he did this whole thing he
acted out Deb getting
raped but it's I'm just telling you I'm
telling you right
now uh I I I wish to God I wasn't rich
and I didn't live in this goddamn
Mansion I wish to God I worked at
Geico what do you mean stop there's
there's no way I'm Ser what do you mean
there's no way I mean you have you don't
understand anything about human nature
the complexities of it you want to go
back is what you're saying if I could
just work at a in a COR in a corporate
environment you
know I'm just saying for a day a day or
two and I would no you know but but you
I'm saying I'm
saying it's fun I would love to get a
fun laugh and it's Corp it's a corporate
we're all in there this [__] company
not what it was we're all sitting there
we go it's not what it was this company
huh used to work here used to be treated
differently they don't treat us they
don't treat us well anymore just to be
with a bunch of bitter losers bitter
resentful losers again getting mad at a
company they barely understand being
angry eating big sandwiches and being
angry with people hating [__] that
person [__] him how did he get that deal
his father is of course godamn it of
course you know it's
great I ruined my goddamn
life I want to go back I want to work
for a
shady Financial comp not like really bad
but just kind of like you know just have
those moments again the corporate moment
your lunch has arrived your lunch has
arrived your lunch has arrived chicken
cutlet honey pesto Mayo roasted red
peppers on chabata a little side of
macaroni salad or tomato salad and
hatred hatred and
anger and pomposity to be pompous and to
know better and when the young guys come
in you go you don't really know how it
works I'll tell you how it works you
seem like a good kid like the
paramilitary structure of it all it's
beautiful it's [__] it's actually be
it's actually
beautiful compared to
Hamas compared to the other options you
know sex trafficking in Thailand or
whatever
yeah I'm telling you in certain
countries they put their own children in
sex
trafficking I think it's better to
work at
IBM I know it crushes your dreams I know
you want to be Fiona
Apple I know everybody wants to be Fiona
Apple out there and everybody's that
just wants to go to Fiona Apple and be
deep
I know or Phoebe
[Music]
Bridges i' I'd respect phe Bridges more
if she worked at
IBM
personally if she had all the talent she
did but still like she worked she would
never like she wouldn't quit she worked
at American Express
like like Phoebe Bridgers and she sold
American Express cards at her concerts
like all these people you know wandered
in and they're all sad and she's got
great music but she's making them sadder
with that you know Sullivan or whatever
she sings that street song about the
street it is very good it's like a nice
sad Christmas song she's got a bunch of
them and and she's like after that and
then she goes and then she goes now you
all know also know that I work at
American Express and
everyone's and she goes I want to tell
you about a few of the benefits of this
card and then she like you know starts
doing interest rates and points and
everything and why do you have to why do
you have to choose one or the other why
do you have to choose one or the other
Kevin Hart's not he's B Chase he's got a
card out now he's got a card God I'd
love a card what about the Dylan card
Chase wouldn't do it who would do it hex
no we'd have to go we we got to go we we
got to go
low we got to find like a a teacher like
a Teacher's Credit Union for like you
know I mean we got to find like some
real scumbag
Arrangement I'm just telling you like I
this was a very the depth of this
episode is going to escape people
because people don't know how lucky they
are this is my point my point is this
and it's pretty it's a pretty Salient
Point people do not know how lucky they
are when there this this this mundane
life that you've
created is actually great this life of
nothing is actually good this life of
like oo someone brought Donuts is
actually good it's actually Peak
civilization how about that how about
that it's actually Peak civilization to
just get up roll out of bed head into
some office with a bunch of clowns eat a
dut and then just email somebody that
they've been denied for new liver or
whatever whatever the whatever the work
is doesn't even matter what the work is
you just email someone you go we're not
paying for that operation figure it out
and then you have a lunch with the guys
this this is Peak it's Peak and we're
past Peak not to be the bearer of bad
news but that's Peak Peak civilization
is like I'm bored at work I'm bored
don't you think the people in Gaza want
to be bored at work don't you think they
want to be the choosing which coffee
creamer to use you know it it it really
is sometimes I think I'm too smart for
the for to communicate with others and
that I should just sit kind of like The
Giver remember him that even speak no he
just took it all in and that's where I
think sometimes I am because I keep
trying to communicate with others and
I'm at a loss because who would defend
American Express who would defend Geico
who would say that that's the meaning of
life but it is all these people write
about the meaning of life it really is
to work at Geo that's the meaning of
life like the meaning of life not not
you
know you know there's a lot of meanings
of life but one of the meanings of life
is to figure it
out to figure out how to just have food
and shelter you need you have basic
needs that need to get met and sometimes
you meet like no matter what you end up
doing there's going to be periods of
your life that you're going to work at
places you don't like you know this is
what's going to H you're not EV
everybody's not going to be uh I don't
know the people on Stranger Things those
kids like and they they're gonna pay
late they're gonna pay later they get to
pay later and everyone pays everyone pay
you don't get out without paying you
know
so what I'm saying and and a lot of
people might disagree with me is that a
a deadend corporate
gig where you're not too low and you're
not too high and you're just kind of
riding in the
middle and you're going uh you got a
couple of free tickets to the game
you're taking some client he's a real
schmuck but you know he might reup with
you you realize that's it that is every
you did it you did it cuz the war The
World Is War and hell and famine and
chaos and you know or or people taking
iasa in their Rolls-Royce try to figure
out how deep is it how do I I need to
actualize but that's what it comes down
to so when you look at the state of
chaos it's all over the world the idea
that you have some boring deadend
corporate job is actually quite an
accomplishment not only of you but of
the people around you yes or yes be
happy with those things fight for
them fight for the office we're going
back we're going back where go where's
that energy it's all for Israel and the
Palestine where is the energy to go back
into the office to crawl back into it
crawl into it we're going back we're
going
back
protest get your fat ass back in the
office cuz Deb is a sick [__] and you
want to tell someone about it you I'm
telling your life will not get better
fight for this no one's going to listen
to
me God they'll play this years from now
years from now after the people in this
town have had me killed years from now
someone will hear this and they go God
he was [__] right God he was right we
should have fought for the shitty Little
Deli in the basement of the building we
should have fought fought for our office
we should have fought for the breakroom
we should have fought for it for
civilization we should have fought when
we had the chance we didn't because we
were all
pompus and we all thought we were better
than that and we didn't need it we
didn't need to see each other in the
flesh or talk to each other that life
was a series of gigs or
[Music]
schemes jobs were for
losers schemes were better gigs were
better even though they only enriched
the [__] apps on our phones and kept
us on a Perpetual wheel offered us
nothing in the way of cohesive social
environments we all became lonely freaks
in our cars our houses our apartments on
messenger bikes task rabbit showing up
inst stalling a TV and then
leaving all of this stuff we didn't
fight for the Great American office the
great dead end job the great middle
class mediocre God I wish I had [__]
applied myself in college and I wouldn't
be in this dump the great backyard beer
with your neighbor [__] this place 30
years they tell you to [__] off at the
end I'm telling you you didn't fight for
it when you had the chance
the biggest regret of my life is that I
don't work in an insurance
company in
Ohio the
privilege the
privilege you think I like driving this
Bentley it ruins every other
car I'm in a rental right now it's it's
insane it's an Infinity it's insane
I don't even know how it even happens
this Infinity truck is
horrible my greatest regret in my life
is that I do not work in Insurance in
Ohio be
smart fight for these things I'm telling
you so many of you are not smart enough
to understand this episode it's very
hard it's very hard for me how do I have
a career at
all
right you're right because now I was
killed in a
tunnel by
mr6 and the mord all right all right you
keep doing this all the time but you're
right I actually believe that the
happiest I've ever been is not when I
was going to Africa pretending to care
about the babies the happiest I've ever
been was when I was in a bank with my
our girlfriends and we was all talking
about who had bigger dicks the or the
bankers which Banker had the biggest
dick that was really fun I didn't lock
Africa it was
depressing that's Princess Diana saying
what we all
know well I I hope do do you understand
what I'm saying you you've shook your
head multiple times but is it it's be
it's so hard I think to fully grasp if
you're not a a full
genius I'm not as as enlightened is you
but I I do see where you're coming from
I do see you know how the the mundanity
can be enjoyable it is it is not only is
it enjoyable it is it that is it that is
it that is it that is it enjoy that
there's a few Great Moments and a few
terrible ones but in that in what you do
every day is what your life is people
don't realize that and they don't
realize the purpose that serves they're
always looking for something else it's
very American to do that by the way this
holiday season just don't treat yourself
to one time gift give the gift that
keeps on giving all year round with box
of Awesome from bespoke post every month
the box of awesome is filled with
carefully chosen gear from the best
small Brands around the world let's see
what I got this month my box this month
um had really cool stuff in it I had
this little uh mini candle that was
really cool like a little candle like a
fall with a
fall fall scent and
um it was really beautiful to have it
and I enjoyed it and it also had I had a
a pack of nuts like mix nuts with you
know with the the way they do them with
the fall kind of fall smoke Smoky and
sweet the
flavors and
um I had
[Music]
um a lot of stuff in there trying to
remember what the other third thing I
had white white
phosphorus the spoke post is offering
tons of discounts through the holidays
so there's it's never been a better time
to sign up to get started take the quiz
at box ofawesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories this is true it's a great
gift to give each box is valued around
70 bucks but you only pay a fraction of
that price plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting small business 90% of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small upand cominging
brand this is great you got people
moving different place going to college
whatever it is just is like you send
this to
somebody and every month they REM
they're reminded of how cool you are and
what a good person you
are get 20% off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box ofawesome.com
and enter the code Tim Dillan a checkout
that's box of that's Box ofawesome.com
codee Tim Dillan for 20% off your first
box box of awesome.com code Tim Dillan
30% of all fatal accidents occur between
6 p.m. and midnight people aged 25 to 34
has the highest amount of drivers
involved in car
crashes people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to the car accidents of all age
groups folks you got to watch out you
got to protect yourself Morgan and
Morgan Americans America's largest
injury Law Firm they have over 100
offices Nationwide more than 800 lawyers
they've gotten over1 155 billion dollars
recovered for their 300,000 clients
they've got a proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation Morgan and Morgan has been
fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan Morgan is so easy I'm telling you
got to do it if it happens if you're in
trouble reach out they're going to help
this is what they do don't go with
alone don't bear the
burden
yourself reach out to a personal injury
law fir like Morgan and
Morgan so many people out there they're
like I just carry this burden myself
don't do that get
help qu to action oh [__] sorry if
you're ever injured you could check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthe
people.im or dial pound law pound 529
from your cell phone that's
forthepeople.com Tim or dial pound law
pound 529 from your sell this is a paid
advertisement because I can't get
another
job although I'd love to I would like
you to go to Tim Dyan comedy.com
and see the shows on the rest of the
tour Detroit Toronto
Austin Brad New Year's Columbus Ohio
Bethlehem Pennsylvania Washington DC
Northfield Ohio San Antonio Texas Dallas
Texas Atlanta Georgia St Louis Missouri
Indianapolis Indiana Boston
Massachusetts and Foxwoods in
Connecticut we've also Ed shamberg
improv and the Dania improv in Florida
they should be on sale I believe sham
BG's in Chicago Danel Beach is in
Florida
um I sincerely hope everybody had a
great uh Thanksgiving and I sincerely
hope everybody found ways to navigate uh
the social climate at your
parties
um we have uh we're recording an episode
with our special guest surprise guest
hopefully will make some people happy
and some people won't be happy and these
are this is the thing right isn't that
the
thing and I I'm gonna sign off now but I
wish I wish let me tell you what I wish
I was doing but I wish I was doing I
wish I was logging out of my
computer
pushing back I still have a similar
chair was a very similar chair to my
office pushing back from my
desk getting
up you know someone's look at me they go
ah quitting time huh I go yeah they go
yeah you're in late tonight you know
it's 6:15 they're being a wise ass oh
you're late tonight I'm burning the
midnight oil like go yeah you know we're
just couple of guys are G to go get a
drink go yep you walk out you stand in
that that parking lot that that that
that kind of empty parking lot you get
in your car it's not the nicest but it's
not the
worst you you turn on the radio and your
your song's on and one of the songs that
you like is on that you really enjoy and
youy you listen to Classic Rock and you
drive out of the little industrial park
and it's a pretty good day it's a pretty
good day because you're living you're
living your dream and you don't even
realize it you don't even realize that
you're living your dream that's actually
the only dreams you can live the ones
you don't
realize and you're driving in your car
and you're happy and this is not going
to end with you getting killed on the
highway which is every story I tell ends
with like oh your your sideswipe in the
highway
um but you get to the bar and there's a
couple of the guys at the bar and you're
sitting there and you have a cocktail
and you have a drink and you know you're
sitting there and you're you're just
joking around about
nothing and you're like it's all nothing
everything we do is nothing and the
breeze hits you in a certain
way and you put your phone down for a
minute and you're just kind of watching
the game or having drinks with a few
people and maybe you got a couple of
kids Maybe not maybe you got a wife
Maybe not maybe there maybe you're a
single guy and you're young you're
starting your thing out maybe you're in
between people or whatever but for the
moment things are fine you're you're
you're there you're alive and you need
nothing else on the planet that's all
you need and all we have done is told
people that they need much much more
than that that's the problem all you
need is life that's not all I need but
it's all you need